d'enlèvement du maire de milito paul
dans le sud de l'ukraine et le fait que
des équipes de journalistes britanniques
et néerlandais et été la cible de tirs
depuis le début de l'invasion selon
reporters sans frontières illustre la
nécessité plus que jamais d'avoir une
presse libre une presse qui peut
effectuer son travail en toute sécurité
pour départager le vrai du faux en temps
de guerre ici donc en ukraine c'est pour
ça qu'il y a la création de ce centre
pour la liberté de presse à lviv dans
l'ouest de l'ukraine on va fournir de
l'équipement de protection journaliste
donc veste pare-balles casque et aussi
des trousses de premiers soins et
surtout des séances de formation pour
les médias ukrainiens les journalistes
ukrainiens qui n'était pas
nécessairement préparés selon reporters
sans frontières à devenir du jour au
lendemain des reporters de guerre dans
leur propre pays on peut écouter le
secrétaire général de reporters sans
frontières à qui j'ai parlé aujourd'hui
pour l'instant on n'est pas du tout dans
la situation
des centaines de journalistes tués en
irak
dizaines et les dizaines tuées en syrie
mais quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé
au port de ces dernières semaines dont
on voit certaines des pratiques de
l'armée russe on peut qu'être
extrêmement inquiet pour les
journalistes ukrainiens et pour les
journalistes étrangers qui sont
extrêmement nombreux à couvrir ce
conflit ce ne sont pas des reporters qui
sont allés à la guerre c'est la guerre
qui est venu à eux sur place il y aura
aussi accès à un centre de travail pour
les médias donc on aura branchement à
internet accès à différentes sources
d'information qui sont fiables parce que
l'autre volet de cette de ce centre de
la liberté de presse c'est de combattre
la désinformation qui est très présente
ici en ukraine évidemment avec les
médias russes qui sont tombés dans la
propagande selon leurs reporters sans
frontières est aussi selon les
différentes sources d'information pas
toujours fiable qu'on voit souvent
retweeter ou dents parmi les
publications sur facebook dont on veut
c'est s'attaquer à cette désinformation
là qui est très présente sur les médias
sociaux mais reporters sans frontières
insiste que c'est le travail des
journalistes mais aussi des citoyens de
bien s'informer on peut écouter
secrétaire général chaque citoyen un
rôle à jouer en tant que
électeurs en tant que l'acteur
démocratique pour lutter contre la
désinformation ce centre de presse a été
établi à lviv dans l'ouest de l'ukraine
parce que c'est devenu le centre la base
de travail en fait de d'organismes
humanitaires mais aussi de nombreux
journalistes étrangers qui peuvent
travailler quand même en toute sécurité
ici et planifier des déplacements par
exemple vers kiev et mario paul des
endroits où les combats font rage et si
philippe leblanc radio canada vivent en
ukraine